[Applause]  the idea  here's the idea we've found some of our  studio audience members so interesting  so inspiring we were moved to write  songs about you Billy let's find our  first subject welcome to the show  the missing Hemsworth brother that guy  got off easy that's you know you got off  real easy next who's up next  [Music]  Evelyn Oh Carolyn Carolyn sweet Carolyn  we hope your name  otherwise this was a waste of time  [Applause]  next up his name is Willie and his neck  is Jeremy buttons his shirt to the top  [Applause]  that's out he's here to get laid and  then he wants to get paid he's la's most  unlikely  [Applause]  that's how every gigolo I know signs off  m'lady and finally we got time for one  more  [Music]  [Applause]  you  you